it's possible that
a human-like intelligent civilization
has previously existed on earth
the reason i say this is like it is
jarring to think that we would not if
they weren't extinct we wouldn't be able
to find evidence of them
after a sufficient amount after a
sufficient amount of time
of course there's like uh look basically
humans like if we destroy ourselves now
human civilization destroy ourselves now
after sufficient amount of time we would
not be
we'd find the evidence of the dinosaurs
we would not find evidence
of humans yeah that's kind of an odd
thing to think about although
i'm not sure if we have enough knowledge
about
species going back for billions of years
we could we could
we might be able to eliminate that
possibility but it's an interesting
question
of course this is a similar question to
you know there were lots of intelligent
species throughout the without our
galaxy
that have all disappeared yeah that's
super sad that um
there exactly that there there may have
been much
more intelligent alien civilizations in
our galaxy that are no longer there
yeah um you actually talked about this
um that humans might destroy ourselves
yeah
and how we might preserve our knowledge
yeah and advertise that knowledge
to other advertisers a funny word to use
from there's no financial gain in this
uh you know like make it like from a
tourism perspective make it interesting
can you describe how well there's a
couple things i broke down into two
parts
actually three parts one is um
you know there's a lot of things we know
that what if what if we were to what if
we
ended one of our civilization collapsed
yeah i'm not talking
tomorrow yeah we could be a thousand
years from alex you know we don't really
know but
but historically would be likely at some
point time flies when you're having fun
yeah that's a good way to put it um
you know could we and then then
intelligent life evolved again on this
planet
wouldn't they want to know a lot about
us and what we knew when they wouldn't
be able to ask us questions
so one very simple thing i said how
would we archive what we know
that was a very simple idea i said you
know what that wouldn't be that hard but
a few satellites
you know going around this in the sun
and we upload wikipedia every day and
um that kind of thing so you know if we
end up killing ourselves well it's
up there and the next intelligence
species will find it and learn something
that would be they would like that they
would appreciate that
um uh so that's one thing the next thing
i said well what if you know
how to outside of our solar system we
have the seti program we're looking for
these intelligent signals from everybody
and if you do a little bit of math which
i did in the book uh and you say well
what if intelligent
species only live for 10 000 years
before you know technologically
intelligent species like ones are really
able to do this
we're just starting to be able to do um
well the chances are we wouldn't be able
to see any of them because they would
have all been disappeared by now
um they would they've lived for 10 000
years and now they're gone
and so we're not going to find these
signals being sent from these people
because
i said what kind of signal could you
create that would last a million years
or a billion years
that someone would say damn it someone
smart lived there
we know that that would be a
life-changing event for us to figure
that out
well what we're looking for today in the
study program isn't that we're looking
for very
coded signals in some sense um and so i
asked myself what would be a different
type of signal one could create
um i've always thought about this
throughout my life and in the book i
gave one
one possible suggestion which was um
uh we now detect planets going around
other other suns
uh other stars excuse me and we do that
by seeing this the
the slight dimming of the light as the
planets move in front of them that's how
we detect uh planets elsewhere in our
galaxy
what if we created something like that
that just rotated around our
our around the sun and it blocked out a
little bit of light in a particular
pattern that someone said
hey that's not a planet that is a sign
that someone was once there you can say
what if it's beating up pi you know
three point whatever
um so the idea of a distance you can
from a distance
broadly broadcast takes no continue
activation on our part this is the key
right no one has to be sitting here
running a computer and supplying it with
power
it just goes on so we go it's continues
and and i argue that part of the study
program should be looking for signals
like that
and to look for signals like that you
ought to figure out what the how would
we create a signal
like what would we create that would be
like that that would persist
for millions of years that would be
broadcast broadly you could see from a
distance
that was unequivocal came from an uh by
an intelligent species and so i gave
that one example
um because they don't know what i know
of actually and then and then finally
right if if our
ultimately our solar system will die at
some point in time
you know how do we go beyond that and i
think
it's possible if at all possible we'll
have to create intelligent machines that
travel throughout this
throughout the the solar system or
throughout the galaxy
and i don't think that's going to be
humans i don't think it's going to be
biological
organisms so these are just things to
think about you know like what's the
you know like i don't i don't want to be
like the dinosaurs i don't want to just
live and like
that was it we're done you know well
there's a kind of presumption that we're
going to live forever which
uh i i think it is a bit sad
to imagine that the message we send as
as you talk about
is that we were once here
instead of we are here well it could be
we are still here
uh but it's more of a it's more of an
insurance
policy in case we're not here you know
well
i don't know but there's something i
think about
we as humans don't often think about
this but
it's like like whenever i um
record a video i've done this a couple
times in my life i've recorded a video
for my future self just for personal
just for fun and it's always just
fascinating
to think about that preserving yourself
for future civilizations for me it was
preserving myself for a future
me but that's a little that's a little
fun example
of archival well these podcasts are are
preserving you and i
in a way yeah for future uh hopefully
well after we're gone but you don't
often we're sitting here talking about
this
you are not thinking about the fact that
you and i are going to die
and there will be like 10 years after
somebody watching this
and we're still alive you know in some
sense i do
i'm here because i want to talk about
ideas and these ideas
transcend me and they transcend this
time
in on our planet um
we're talking here about ideas that
could be around a thousand years from
now or a million years from now
i when i wrote my book i had an audience
in mind
and one of the clearest audiences was
aliens
no were people reading this 100 years
from now yes
i said to myself how do i make this book
relevant to summer reading this 100
years from now what would they want to
know that we were thinking back then
what would make it like
that was an interesting it's still an
interesting book i'm not sure i can
achieve that but that was how i thought
about it because these ideas
like especially in the third part of the
book the ones we're just talking about
you know these crazy
it sounds like crazy ideas about you
know storing our knowledge and
and you know merging our brains of
computers and sending
you know our machine down to space is
not going to happen in my lifetime
um and they may not maybe happen the
next hundred years it may not happen for
a thousand years who knows
uh but we have the unique opportunity
right now
we you me and other people like this um
to
sort of at least propose the agenda
um that might impact the future like
that that's a fascinating way to think
uh both
like writing or creating try to make
try to create ideas try to create things
that uh
hold up in time yeah you know
understanding how the brain works
we're gonna figure that at once that's
it it's gonna be figured out once
and after that that's the answer and
people will people will study that
thousands of years now we still we still
you know venerate newton and einstein
and um and you know because
because ideas are exciting even well
into the future
well the interesting thing is like big
ideas even if they're wrong
are still useful like
yeah especially if they're not
completely wrong like
right newton's laws are not wrong
they're just einsteins they're
better right so um well it's
so yeah i mean but we're talking with
newton and einstein we're talking about
physics i wonder
if we'll ever achieve that kind of
clarity but understanding um
like complex systems and the this
particular manifestation of complex
systems which is the
human brain i'm totally optimistic we
can do that i mean
we're making progress at it i don't see
any reasons why we can't
completely i mean completely understand
in the sense um
you know we don't really completely
understand what all the molecules in
this water bottle are doing
but you know we have laws that sort of
capture it pretty good um
and so we'll have that kind of
understanding i mean it's not like
you're gonna have
know what every neuron in your brain is
doing um
but enough to uh first of all to build
it
and second of all to do you know do what
physics does which is like have uh
concrete experiments where we can
validate we're we're this is happening
right now like
it's not this is not some future thing
um
you know i'm very optimistic about
because i know about art our work and
what we're doing
well i have to prove it to people um but
um
i i consider myself a rational person
and
um you know until fairly recently i
wouldn't have said that but right now
i'm where i'm sitting right now i'm
saying you know we
can this is going to happen there's no
big obstacles to it
um we finally have a framework for
understanding what's going on in the
cortex
and um and that's liberating
it's it's like oh it's happening so i i
can't see why we wouldn't be able to
understand it i just can't
okay oh so i mean on that topic let me
ask you to play devil's advocate
is it possible for you to imagine
look a hundred years from now and
looking at your
book uh in which ways
might your ideas be wrong oh i worry
about this all the time
um yeah
still useful yeah yeah
i think there's you know um well
i can i can best relate it to like
things i'm worried about right now
so we talk about this voting idea right
it's happening there's no question
that's happening
but it could be far more uh
there's there's enough things i don't
know about it that it might be
working in ways differently i'm thinking
about the kind of what's voting who's
voting
you know where are representations i
talked about you have a thousand models
of a coffee cup
like that that could turn out to be
wrong um because it may be
maybe there are a thousand models that
are sub models but not really a single
model the coffee cup
um i mean there's things these are all
sort of on the edges
things that i i present as like oh it's
so simple and clean well it's not that
it's always going to be more complex
and um and there's
parts of the theory which i don't
understand the complexity well so
i think i think the idea is brain is a
distributed modeling system is
not controversial at all right it's not
that's well understood by many people
the question then is are each quarter of
a column an independent modeling system
right um i could be wrong about that
um i don't think so but i worry about it
my intuition not even thinking why you
could be wrong
is the same intuition i have about any
sort of physicist
like strength theory that we as humans
desire for a clean explanation
and a hundred years from now
intelligent systems might look back at
us and laugh
at how we try to get rid of the whole
mess by
having simple explanation when the
reality is it's
it's way messier and in fact it's
impossible to understand you can only
build it it's like this idea of complex
systems and
cellular automata yeah you can only
launch the thing you cannot understand
it
yeah i think that you know the history
of science suggests that's not likely to
occur
um the history of science suggests that
look
as a theorist and we're theorists you
look for simple explanations right
fully knowing that whatever simple
explanation you're going to come up with
is not going to be completely correct i
mean it can't be
i mean it's just it's just more
complexity but that's the role of
theorists play
they they sort of they give you a
framework on which you now can talk
about a problem and
figure out okay and now we can start dig
in more details
the best frameworks stick around while
the details change
you know again you know the classic
example is newton and einstein right you
know
um newton's theories are still used
they're still valuable they're still
practical they're not like wrong
just they've been refined yeah but
that's in physics it's not
obvious by the way it's not obvious for
physics either
that the universe should be such that
it's amenable to these
simple but it's so far it appears to be
as far as we can tell
um yeah i mean but as far as we could
tell
and but it's also an open question
whether the brain is amenable to such
clean theories that's the uh not the
brain but intelligence
well i i i don't know i would take
intelligence out of it just say you know
um well okay
um the evidence we have suggests that
the human brain
is this is a at the one time extremely
messy and complex but there's some parts
that are very regular and structured
that's why we started the neocortex it's
extremely regular in its structure
yeah and unbelievably so and then i
mentioned earlier the other thing is
it's it's universal abilities it is
so flexible to learn so many things we
don't
we haven't figured out what it can't
learn yet we don't know but we haven't
figured out yet but he learns things
that it never was evolved to learn
so those give us hope um that's why i
went into this field because i said you
know
this regular structure it's doing this
amazing number of things there's got to
be some underlying principles that are
that are common and other other
scientists have come up with the same
conclusions
um and so it's promising it's promising
and um and that's and whether the
theories
play out exactly this way or not that is
the role that theorists play
and so far it's worked out well even
though you know maybe
you know we don't understand all the
laws of physics but so far it's been
pretty damn useful the ones we have
are our theories are pretty useful
you